where do the raiders go from here with
much of the season still ahead sports
director chris matthews continues our
team coverage well thank you denise with
gruden out assistant head coach rich
biasia will take over on an interim
basis just a few months ago mark mark
bedan the president of the raiders
stepped down and then grunting today an
avalanche of controversy resigning
gruden released in a statement saying he
didn't want to be a distraction to all
the players coaches in raider nation
saying he's sorry never meant to hurt
anyone one thing the nfl is trying to do
is change a culture and gruden stomped
on the face of that initiative you'll
see painted signs in the end zone of nfl
fields with the words stop racism stop
hate inspire change and it takes all of
us gruden resigned so raiders owner mark
davis didn't have to make a decision a
change needed to take place and davis
made sure it did that's the one shining
attribute the raiders have is diversity
inclusion first franchise to hire an
hispanic coach a black coach and a
female executive and former raider
player and former head of nevada's naacp
spoke about the raiders owner and the
future moving forward
mark davis comes from
as we would say good stop
he knows right from wrong he has
held himself out
to be he's growing
into a great owner and he understands a
new start he understands what he wants
to build the raiders into his vision
all right and going forward it had to be
without gruden his resignation was
announced on espn monday night football
where he worked for a decade and by the
way john sunduce remains with the
raiders as strength and conditioning
coach